was hast du gesagt hast du hast mir
scheißegal
guck dir erstmal an vielleicht sollte
ich mal ein bisschen weniger von diesen
schokoriegel erst ein bisschen was
gesünderes dk was ist das für ein lehrer
wer hat diesen lehrer ausgebildet wo
kommt er her wie herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute ich glaube wir
haben alle in unserer schulzeit gute und
auch schlechte erfahrungen gemacht ich
für meinen teil denkt zum beispiel an
meine leicht seine mathelehrerin die
einen gerne wahr angespuckt hat wenn man
vorher gesessen hat oder mein
englischlehrer der ich von der schule
schmeißen wollte das aber gott sei dank
nicht geschafft hat aber diese ganzen
lehre an die wir denken diese wirklich
schlimm menschen mit denen wir uns in
unserem schulalltag auseinandersetzen
müssen sind nichts gegen psycho lehrer
harry dann falls euch jetzt fragt
sebastian wer ist psycho lehrer harry
seht selbst
ok also gut
ja das hier ist scheinbar unser psycho
lehrer harry der hat anscheinend eine
trillerpfeife im unterricht dabei und
sieht auch sonst nicht so wirklich aus
wir sind lehrer mehr wieso ein drill
sergeant von der armee okay man muss
aber auch sagen der was geht mit dieser
klasse ab einer hat die füße auf den
tisch der andere frist gerade chips in
sich rein
zwei sind am telefonieren ja also kurz
gesagt 100 prozent von dieser klasse in
der vier leute sind was wirklich sinn
macht machen scheiße jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wie psycho harry damit umgeht
glaube mein name harry laufe ich habe
den auftrag
ich warte mal zu bringen damit ihr euren
abschluss gekriegt also ich weiß nicht
was es ist leute aber irgendwas sagt mir
dass dieser typ hier möglicherweise ein
bisschen geisteskrank ist auch schule
okay aber auch ganz kurz ich musste sehr
schnell unterbrechen leute weil was zur
hölle geht hier ab dekker ist es
unterricht oder ist ein fucking picknick
alter derer die am einfach ein halbes
supermarkt sortiment auf ihren tischen
rumliegen ganzen sachen weg man muss so
weit aber noch sagen okay also der typ
also der hat höchstwahrscheinlich ein
dachschaden okay der sitzt mit einer
trillerpfeife im klassenzimmer und
trillert dass seine schüler an video
etwas machen was ihm nicht passt aber in
dem fall muss man auch sagen so was soll
er machen so vier schüler sitzen vor ihm
und mampfen sich ein abdecker als wenn
sie gar von fucking marathon
zurückgekommen da muss man als lehrer
immer durchgreifen
das kriegt ihr nach der und nach dem
unterricht wieder
er beriet leute warum sind in dieser
klasse nur vier schüler was ist mit dem
rest der klasse haben klassen so
normalerweise an deutschlands schulen
nicht so 20 30 schüler
wo ist der rest in der shisha bar im
kopf ist okay wir mussten jetzt kommt
der psycho teilweise durch hatte gerade
wirklich gefragt was ist das was du da
auf dem kopf hast das ist als aussage
von einem lehrer schon menschenrechte
sind ziemlich abstoßend aber ihre
antwort ist auch nicht schlecht haare 2
fuchs schweiger fuchs schweiger fuchs
ich will dass keiner von euch redet den
speicher fox hier ist also ich glaube
das ist ein keine effektive methode um
16 17 jährige eine hauptschule zu
beruhigen über den schweige fuchs ins
gesicht hält so was soll passieren was
stellt sich dieser lehrer vor was ich
höre da denken so nur zu sagen ich rede
ok schweige fuchs
vor allem er sieht so aus wie so ein
kneipen schläger alter er sieht so aus
als würde keine ahnung sich wirklich und
nach dem unterricht auf der straße
einfach boxen mit irgendwelchen
hooligans und er packt einfach den
schwaiger fuchs aus ja okay also mein
auftrag ist es euch matte beizubringen
aber nicht so den ersten eindruck lohnt
sich der auftrag auf doch gar nicht was
hat jetzt gesagt hatte die jetzt
beleidigt so dass rtl2 das piepsen
musste ja also man muss sagen die die
maßnahmen die dieser lehrer an den tag
legt ist wirklich hoch effektiv sollte
man wirklich auch genauso machen also
der erste schritt ist immer um die
kontrolle in die klassenräume zu bringen
erst mal die trillerpfeife benutzen dann
getränke auf die schüler schützen ganz
wichtig dann natürlich ultimativ leute
der schweige fuchs funktioniert immer
und dann wenn man das gemacht hat sollte
man um die stimmung wieder ein bisschen
aufzuheitern erstmal die schüler
beleidigen
ich sehe schon auf die stirn geschrieben
was immer irgendwann werdet also er
redete darüber dass er von seinen
schülerinnen denken seinen schülern also
was seiner meinung nach so die berufe
sind die sie später machen werden und
die berufe die ihr nennt sind einfach
beleidigung was hat er gesagt du wirst
note oder ok als elfte gesagt da hätten
das zuhälter und jetzt bin ich gespannt
was wird da hinten rechts selber schon
eine rosige zukunft vor sich
[Musik]
ja
der schüler wird bodybuilder oder big
boss rapper ja manchmal bräuchte dass
wir in deutschland leben heute bei ganz
ehrlich werden jetzt einfach alle in
amerika gab es wird deutlich leichter
einfach eine waffe zu kommen um sich ein
kopfschuss zu geben
den kleinen dicken da draußen goethe
oder du gehst raus und macht erstmal los
mach was ist okay also der erste aber
von diesem klassenraum ist also ist er
wirklich eine mischung aus picknick und
rap battle so krass wie die sich
gegenseitig beleidigen als ein ort an
dem unterricht stattfindet ok zehn
sekunden später die eine mit der
besonderen frisur die psycho lehrerin
ist gefallen hat sich abriss einer
sonnenbrille aufgesetzt mit dem
unterricht währenddessen ist ein neuer
schüler reingekommen der so aussieht als
hätte sich vom physik leistungskurs am
gymnasium hier erfährt also das geht
ganz normal weiter
die respektieren april schweiger fuchs
nicht es sind die vorhanden sind
was haltet ihr das letzte mal drauf was
wir zuletzt in mathe aufwartet ich habe
das gefühl er hat auch nicht wirklich so
ein plan davon was er macht
wir konnten diese klasse ryanair kennt
keinen einzigen namen von irgendeinem
schüler da irgendwas schülerin er weiß
nicht was die überhaupt gemacht haben im
unterricht also es soll ja schon mal
mitten im schuljahr sein weil er fragt
was sie auf hatten ja aber scheinbar
wechseln an dieser schule die lehrer
täglich hier
es macht überhaupt keinen sinn also real
tor
diese folge macht überhaupt keinen sinn
mal wieder warum weiß ja nicht wie die
schüler heißen warum weiß ja nicht was
ihr auf haben und wieso verteilt der in
der klasse von der überhaupt keine
ahnung hat erst mal einen test candy und
ihre mitschüler hassen den lehrer und
seine methoden jetzt schon
doch das ist erst der anfang was was
noch passieren was soll dieser lehrer
noch machen er hat schon er hat die
picknicks im klassenzimmer verboten er
hat den die handys abgenommen
der typ ist wahnsinnig der sogar
verboten dass man im unterricht
sonnenbrillen trägt aber die kürzung
mach die tür zu also du wirst jetzt war
ohne wird das ist kein normales
verhältnis zwischen schülern und lehrern
da geht's auch nicht mehr darum den
leuten irgendwas beizubringen oder so
jetzt ist einfach nur noch schüler und
lehrer beleidigen sich einfach am laufen
band und gucken wir haben ende den
anderen besser gelöst hat macht die tür
zu setzen
mach die tür zu ich habe mir vorgestellt
wie das ausgesehen hätte wenn ich das in
meiner schule gemacht hätte egal ich
wäre ohne witz für die sachen die die
schüler in dem video gemacht haben ich
werde schon für so dreimal schon von der
schule geflogen der lehrer von 1 auf die
schürze zu machen sagt einfach sagt
bitte ja ich werde so an das von der
schule geflogen
was hast du gesagt
weißt du ist mir scheißegal guck dir
erstmal an
vielleicht solltest mal ein bisschen
weniger von diesen schokoriegel erst ein
bisschen was gesünderes legal
egal was ist das für ein lehrer wer hat
diesen lehrer ausgebildet wo kommt er
her wie kupfer der versucht einfach
nicht mal den irgend etwas beizubringen
oder irgendwie konstruktiv am
unterrichts klima zu arbeiten das
einzige was er macht ist wirklich
schüler beleidigen ist einfach so dem
einzigen normalen schüler in dieser
klasse also den schokoriegel weg der
schüler fragten warum machen sie das
und er beleidigt ihn einfach als antwort
perfekt kurz darauf terror lehrer harry
fackelt nicht lange und sorgt dafür dass
seine schüler disziplin lernen okay also
hat ist ein schüler aus dem
klassenzimmer vertrieben hat sich jetzt
ganz spontan entschieden dass im
matheunterricht einfach kein mathe
gemacht wird sondern jetzt die jungs und
mädels irgendwie joggen müssen
ich brauchte ich die bilder ja also was
soll man dazu noch sagen alter mir gehen
wirklich auf ganz anderen ebene grad die
gehirnzellen flöten alle larven einfach
nur scheiße in dieser folge
es ist nicht mehr als ein sinnvoller
satz zwischendrin aber jetzt kommt er
wieder hier und sagt das ist sein haupt
schließlich brauche der big boss rapper
wird was sind das für menschen
der nächste tag hardcore harry lässt
sich nichts gefallen
schüler rocky lernt den lehrer von
seiner schlimmsten seite kennen jetzt
nicht ihr ernst
er hat jetzt nicht wirklich als
strafarbeit den schüler als frau
verkleidet und ihm schild umgehängt
das kann es eigentlich nicht wirklich
sein ich habe ganz ehrlich leute schaut
euch das an
ok der schüler ist als frau verteilt hat
ein schild umgehängt drauf steht dumm
geboren und nichts dazugelernt muss sich
dazu noch überhaupt irgendwas sagen das
war es ohne witz komplett weiter jetzt
haben wirklich alle endgültig den
verstand verloren
allen voran psycho lehrer habe es geht
hier um mathe und du siehst aus wie so
eine billige doch gebe es zu ich weiß es
ist also wirklich okay ich habe jetzt
gerade weiter es gibt ja ich habe
weiters gibt es in der nächste tag und
nein
leute ich hoffe ihr verständnis dass ich
an der stelle jetzt wirklich abbrechen
muss falls ihr demnächst im unterricht
das gefühl habe kommt nicht mehr weiter
und ihr braucht irgendwann neue ansätze
könnt ihr eurem lehrer mal das video
hier zeigen 50 oder ihre harry der freut
sich über neue inspirationen ansonsten
habe ich hier drüben ein für euch
persönlich vorgeschlagenes video
verlinkt das was so weit von diesem
video bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut